THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR MORE ANALYSIS, LET'S BRING
IN THE POWER PANEL, RICHARD
FOWLER, FROM
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
FOX NEWS COULD TRIGGER JASON
RILEY, THE FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH, BRIAN
BLAKEMAN.
GENTLEMEN, WELCOME TO ALL OF
YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Shannon: BRAD, I WANT TO
START WITH YOU, BECAUSE YOU WERE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE RECOUNT IN
2000, YOU KNOW THIS IS LIKE.
NOW WE HAVE MULTIPLE STATES
WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING, TO
LEHMAN BY TORT'S POINT, THEY
HAVE BEEN PREPARING FOR ALL
POSITIVITY'S, VOTERS ELECTED TO
VOTE BY MAIL, RECEIVING ABSENT
TEEN BALLOT FOR THE RUNOFF, AND
WE JUST APPROVED A TV BUY.
THEY ARE NOT CONCEDING.
>> THEY ARE NOT, BUT THE MATH
DOES NOT WORK IN GEORGIA.
IN MY OPINION, IT IS PUTTING
GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE PUTTING THAT
KIND OF INVESTMENT OUT AND
PUTTING THAT FALSE HOPE OUT TO
THEIR SUPPORTERS.
THEY SHOULD BE CONCEDING.
THERE IS SOMETHING TO BE SAID
ABOUT THE FLORIDA RACES, AS WELL
AS THE ARIZONA RACES.
THOSE ARE CLEARLY NOT OVER UNTIL
EVERY VOTE IS COUNTED THERE.
THE MOUTH IS THERE TO WARRANT
THE KIND OF RECOUNT THAT IS
MANDATORY, BUT CERTAINLY NOT IN
GEORGIA.
>> Shannon: RICHARD, BY
TOMORROW AT 5:00 P.M. -- EXCUSE
ME, BY TUESDAY 5:00 P.M. IN
GEORGIA, ALL THE COUNTIES OR
SPOUSE TO CERTIFY THAT THIS IS
OVER.
I IMAGINE THERE IS GOING TO BE
LASHED BACK IN GEORGIA, BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW HOW -- THE TWO
SIDES ARE SO ENTRENCHED AT THIS
POINT.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
IT WILL DEAFEN AND ABOUT THE
COURTS.
THE IDEA OF A RECOUNT AND HOW
LONG IT TAKES TO ACTUALLY COUNT
VOTES, RIGHT?
I THINK PEOPLE ASSUME ELECTION
NIGHT, MAKING PROJECTIONS, THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY WINNERS, AND THAT
IS NOT NECESSARILY TRUE, THEY
ARE CALLED THE PROJECTIONS FOR A
REASON.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE OF
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE IN EVERY
STATE OF THE UNION TO ACTUALLY
CERTIFY THE ELECTION.
THAT TAKES THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SOMETIMES SEVEN DAYS TO GET DONE
BECAUSE YOU ARE TO COUNT
ABSENTEE BALLOTS FROM THE
MILITARY, ABSENTEE BALLOTS
AREN'T DIPLOMATS, FROM CITIZENS
ABROAD, PROVISIONAL BALLOTS,
THAT TAKES TIME.
INSTEAD OF RUSHING THE PROCESS,
WHICH I'VE SEEN A LOT OF FOLKS
PUSH US TO DO, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT, WHY DON'T WE LET THE
VOTES JUST GET COUNTED?
THAT IS WHAT DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT,
COUNTING VOTES.
>> Shannon: IT TAKES TIME.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WONDERING WHAT
IS GOING ON IN ARIZONA.
EVERY STATE IS ALLOWED TO RUN
THESE THINGS WITHIN CERTAIN
PARAMETERS THE WAY THEY WANT TO.
THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT, YOU
KNOW, STATE STATUTES AND THAT
KIND OF THING.
IN ARIZONA, THE FACT IT IS
TAKING SO LONG, REALLY NOT THAT
UNUSUAL PIER
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WRITES
ABOUT THIS AND SAYS STATE LAW
REQUIRES THE ENVELOPE -- BECAUSE
SO MANY PEOPLE VOTE BY
ARIZONA -- THE ENVELOPE TO BE
SEALED INSIDE AND FOR ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO MATCH EACH
SIGNATURE TO THE ONE ON FILE
WITH THE VOTER REGISTRATION
BEFORE EVEN OPENING THE
ENVELOPE.
IN THE SELECTION, THAT IS ABOUT
1.7 MILLION INDIVIDUAL
SIGNATURES THAT HAD TO BE
CONFIRMED ONE BY ONE, A TOTAL OF
ABOUT 2.3 MILLION VOTES WERE
CAST IN ARIZONA.
THE NEW TOTALS TONIGHT CONTINUE
TO TAKE SINEMA UP, THE
DEMOCRATIC CHALLENGER THERE.
ANY PATH YOU SEE FOR McSALLY
AT THIS POINT, THE REPUBLICAN?
>> IT IS LOOKING TOUGH FOR THE
REPUBLICANS OUT THERE IN
ARIZONA.
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE IS AS
MUCH SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THE
PROCESS GOING ON OUT THERE
AS THERE IS BACK EAST,
PARTICULARLY DOWN IN FLORIDA.
WE KNOW THAT SOME DEMOCRATS HAVE
TROUBLE ACCEPTING THAT THEY HAVE
LOST ELECTIONS.
WE SAW THIS IN 2016, AND IT
LOOKS LIKE IT CONTINUED EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
PARTICULARLY IN SOUTH FLORIDA,
AND BROWARD COUNTY, REPUBLICANS
HAVE REASON TO BE SUSPICIOUS.
THE ELECTION SUPERVISOR THERE
HAS REPEATEDLY REPRIMANDED BY
JUDGES FOR DESTROYING BALLOTS,
ILLEGALLY, COUNTING OTHER
BALLOTS IN SECRET, AND THE REAL
QUESTION IS WHETHER THE
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE GOING IN --
GOING DOWN THERE RIGHT NOW --
ARE THERE BECAUSE OF BALLOT
INTEGRITY OR THEIR TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
AND I THINK THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
RIGHT TO BE SKEPTICAL OF THE
PROCESS.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE SPEND TIME ON FLORIDA TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS.
I WILL ASK YOU TO MOVE A LITTLE
BIT BRISKLY.
BRAD, START WITH YOU.
MARK ELIAS, THE ATTORNEY WHO
REPRESENTS A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
AND IS A HOUSEHOLD NAME TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THESE RACES, AND IN
THESE FIGHTS AND COURTS, HE
SAYS THIS.
BREAKING PROVISIONAL BALLOTS FOR
COUNTED AND COUNTIES CAN BEST,
THE MARGIN ON FLORIDA'S SENATE
RACE HAS FALLEN UNDER 15,000.
I EXPECTED THE MARGIN TOO TIGHT
AND FURTHER IN ADVANCE OF
TOMORROW'S 12:00 DEADLINE PEERED
AS I SAID BEFORE, THIS IS A JUMP
BALL GOING INTO THE RECOUNT,
WHICH COULD BE TROY TRIGGERED
AS SOON AS 3:00 TOMORROW.
>> IT COULD.
THERE'S SOMETHING VERY
SUSPICIOUS, 67 COUNTIES IN
FLORIDA, WHENEVER THERE'S A
PROBLEM, IT ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO
THE DEMOCRATIC STRONGHOLD OF
BROWARD AND PALM BEACH COUNTY.
I WITNESSED FIRSTHAND, THE
GOVERNOR HAD TO BRING A LAWSUIT
IN ORDER TO GET HIS PEOPLE IN
THEIR TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT.
WE HAD TO DO THE SAME THING IN
THE FLORIDA RECOUNT IN 2000.
THERE WERE BALLOTS FOUND IN
TRUNKS OF CARS, HALLWAYS, AND
BALLOT SECURITY WAS NONEXISTENT.
AND SO THE IS IN QUESTION HERE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF
IT.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP
INTEGRITY, BRAD, BECAUSE THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT BODY FOR THE
STATE OF FLORIDA HAS ALREADY
LOOKED INTO THIS AND SAID THEY
SEE NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUD.
>> STILL HAS A JUDGE --
>> Shannon: GUYS, JUST SO
PEOPLE KNOW, THERE HAVE BEEN TWO
RULINGS TODAY THAT SEEM TO
BENEFIT THE SCOTT CAMPAIGN AT
THIS POINT, BECAUSE THERE ARE
STATE STATUTES HERE IN PLAY, AND
REPORTING AND TRANSPARENCY, THAT
NEEDS TO BE -- JASON, I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A FINAL WORD, BECAUSE
BILL SHARE, AN ATTORNEY WHO
WASN'T DEALT WITH A NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS IN BROWARD COUNTY,
SAYS HE HAS BEEN FILING AGAINST
BRENDA SNIPES.
HAVING DOUBTS ABOUT HOW THESE
BOATS ARE LEFT -- THAT IS NOT
FAIR TO THE LEFT OR RIGHT,
DEMOCRATS, ANYBODY WHO VOTED.
>> THERE ARE PROBLEMS WITH THE
ELECTION SUPERVISORS, A TRACK
RECORD OF SHENANIGANS DOWN
THERE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS ALL OF THE VOTES
SHOULD BE COUNTED, BUT WE NEED
CONSISTENT RULES TO MAKE SURE
ALL OF THE VOTES ARE COUNTED THE
RIGHT WAY AND CONSISTENTLY AND
FAIRLY ON BOTH SIDES.
AGAIN, REPUBLICANS HAVE REASON
TO BE SUSPICIOUS.
>> Shannon: GUYS WE ARE GOING
TO RUN OUT OF TIME.
LISTEN, WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
OTHER COURT ORDERS THAT HAVE
BECOME OUT TONIGHT AND ARE GOING
TO KICK IN TOMORROW.
LISTEN, WE KNOW THIS IS FAR, FAR